In this video we're going to do
a couple of examples that
deal with parallel and
perpendicular lines.
So you have parallel, you have
perpendicular, and, of course,
you have lines that are
neither parallel nor
perpendicular.
And just as a bit of review,
if you've never seen this
before, parallel lines,
they never intersect.
So let me draw some axes.
So if those are my coordinate
axes right there, that's my
x-axis, that is my y-axis.
If this is a line that I'm
drawing in magenta, a parallel
line might look something
like this.
It's not the exact same
line, but they have
the exact same slope.
If this moves a certain amount,
if this change in y
over change in x is a certain
amount, this change in y over
change in x is the
same amount.
And that's why they
never intersect.
So they have the same slope.
Parallel lines have
the same slope.
Perpendicular lines, depending
on how you want to view it,
they're kind of the opposite.
Let's say that this
is some line.
A line that is perpendicular
to that will not only
intersect the line, it will
intersect it at a right angle,
at a 90 degree angle.
And I'm not going to prove
it for you here.
I actually prove it in the
linear algebra playlist. But a
perpendicular line's slope--
so let's say that this one
right here, let's say that
yellow line has a slope of m.
Then this orange line, that's
perpendicular to the yellow
line, is going to have a slope
of negative 1 over m.
Their slopes are going
to be the negative
inverse of each other.
Now, given this information,
let's look at a bunch of lines
and figure out if they're
parallel, if they're
perpendicular, or if
they are neither.
And to do that, we just have to
keep looking at the slopes.
So let's see, they say one
line passes through the
points, 4, negative 3,
and negative 8, 0.
Another line passes through
the points, negative 1,
negative 1, and negative 2, 6.
So let's figure out the slopes
of each of these lines.
So I'll first do this
one in pink.
So this slope right here,
so line 1, so I'll
call it slope 1.
Slope 1 is, let's just say it
is-- well, I'll take this as
the finishing point.
So negative 3 minus 0--
remember change in y--
negative 3 minus 0, over
4 minus negative 8.
So this is equal to negative 3
over-- this is the same thing
as 4 plus 8-- negative
3 over 12, which is
equal to negative 1/4.
Divide the numerator and
the denominator by 3.
That's this line.
That's the first line.
Now, what about the
second line?
The slope for that second line
is, well, let's take, here,
negative 1 minus 6, over
negative 1 minus negative 2 is
equal to-- negative 1 minus 6 is
negative 7, over negative 1
minus negative 2.
That's the same thing as
negative 1 plus 2.
Well, that's just 1.
So the slope here
is negative 7.
So here, their slopes are
neither equal-- so they're not
parallel-- nor are
they the negative
inverse of each other.
So this is neither.
This is neither parallel
nor perpendicular.
So these two lines, they
intersect, but they're not
going to intersect at
a 90 degree angle.
Let's do a couple
more of these.
So I have here, once again, one
line passing through these
points, and then another line
passing through these points.
So let's just look
at their slopes.
So this one in the green,
what's the slope?
The slope of the green one, I'll
call that the first line.
We could say, let's
see, change in y.
So we could do negative 2
minus 14, over-- I did
negative 2 first, so I'll
do 1 first-- over 1
minus negative 3.
So negative 2 minus
14 is negative 16.
1 minus negative 3 is the
same things as 1 plus 3.
That's over 4.
So this is negative 4.
Now, what's the slope of that
second line right there?
So we have the slope of
that second line.
Let's say 5 minus negative 3,
that's our change in y, over
negative 2 minus 0.
So this is equal to 5
minus negative 3.
That's the same thing
as 5 plus 3.
That's 8.
And then negative 2 minus
0 is negative 2.
So this is also equal
to negative 4.
So these two lines
are parallel.
They have the exact
same slope.
And I encourage you to find the
equations of both of these
lines and graph both of these
lines, and verify for yourself
that they are indeed parallel.
Let's do this one.
Once again, this is just an
exercise in finding slope.
So this first line
has those points.
Let's figure out its slope.
The slope of this first
line, one line passes
through these points.
So let's see, 3 minus negative
3, that's our change in y,
over 3 minus negative 6.
So this is the same thing as 3
plus 3, which is 6, over 3
plus 6, which is 9.
So this first line has
a slope of 2/3.
What is the second
line's slope?
This was the second line there,
that's the other line
passing through these points.
So the other line's slope,
let's see, we could say
negative 8 minus 4, over
2 minus negative 6.
So what is this equal to?
Negative 8 minus 4
is negative 12.
2 minus negative 6, that's the
same thing as 2 plus 6.
The negatives cancel out.
So it's negative 12 over 8,
which is the same thing if we
divide the numerator and the
denominator by 4, that's
negative 3/2.
Notice, these guys
are the negative
inverse of each other.
If I take negative 1 over 2/3,
that is equal to negative 1
times 3/2, which is equal
to negative 3/2.
These guys are the negative
inverses of each other.
You swap the numerator and the
denominator, make them
negative, and they become
equal to each other.
So these two lines are
perpendicular.
And I encourage you to find the
equations-- I already got
the slopes for you-- but find
the equations of both of these
lines, plot them, and verify
for yourself that they are
perpendicular.
Let's do one more.
Find the equation of a line
perpendicular to this line
that passes through the
point 2 comma 8.
So this first piece of
information, that it's
perpendicular to that line right
over there, what does
that tell us?
Well, if it's perpendicular to
this line, its slope has to be
the negative inverse of 2/5.
So its slope, the negative
inverse of 2/5, the inverse of
2/5 is-- let me do it in a
better color, a nicer green.
If this line's slope is negative
2/5, the equation of
the line we have to figure out
that's perpendicular, its
slope is going to
be the inverse.
So instead of 2/5, it's
going to be 5/2.
Instead of being a negative,
it's going to be a positive.
So this is a negative inverse
of negative 2/5.
Right?
You take the negative sign
and it becomes positive.
You swap the 5 and the
2, you get 5/2.
So that is going to have
to be our slope.
And we can actually use the
point-slope form right here.
It goes through this
point right there.
So let's use point-slope form.
y minus this y-value, which
has to be on the line, is
equal to our slope, 5/2 times
x minus this x-value, the
x-value when y is equal to 8.
And this is the equation of the
line in point-slope form.
If you want to put it in
slope-intercept form, you can
just do a little bit of
algebra, algebraic
manipulation. y minus 8 is equal
to-- let's distribute
the 5/2-- so 5/2 x minus--
5/2 times 2 is just-- 5.
And then add 8 to both sides.
You get y is equal to 5/2x.
Add 8 to negative
5, so plus 3.
And we are done.